well thanks first off I should mention
anybody get the reference to be six to
anybody read the little prince little
prince lived on an asteroid called b612
that's where the name came from I might
tell you the story if you ask me later
but the facetiously call they're saving
the world because there is an outside
chance that it may in fact be the most
important project on this planet right
now and you don't know until you until
you know get to the future and find out
but first off let's start with a little
introduction of all the mechanics I'm
not sure if anybody here comes from
astronomy but I thought it'd be good to
review what the solar system looks like
so here is a map of the solar system
it's uh it's actually is there a way to
get these lights down up here just say
it loudly will it magic up any more is
there a high love it
okay so this is an anatomically accurate
map of the solar system in that we have
taken the the NASA database of every
single known asteroid plotted it here so
they're all correctly rendered well more
than a million in the asteroid belt
ten thousand here this is the earth this
is the Sun Mercury Venus Earth Mars
that's the asteroid belt we don't care
about those asteroids in some sense
because they don't hit us the ones that
are in here called near-earth asteroids
there have been once thrown out of the
asteroid belt and they're in Keplerian
orbits which means they just go round
and round and round around just like the
earth does and you start excuse the
bumpiness this is what happens when you
embed videos in PowerPoint but you can
see if there's a lot of asteroids out
there and they do come very close to the
earth is if you watch the Earth's the
light green line going by however we
know that there are many many more
near-earth asteroids in this because
we've only been able to find about one
less than 1% of them so this is what it
really looks like if you take the same
distribution multiply it by 100 you see
there's a lot of things out there
floating around there in Earth's
vicinity now this is a little bit
deceptive because you have to make the
pixels brighter in order to see them if
you drew them actual real size they'd be
too small to see so again here's the
Earth's orbit and that
is the million or so asteroids larger
than than 40 meters I'll explain why 40
meters is an interesting size so that's
you know it's a little bit bigger than
this room okay this room is probably
about 20 or so meters across so solar
system is a busy place a lot of things
hit the earth
so picture I took on this when I was on
the space station I like this picture
because it cannot be taken from the
ground because you notice that this is
in the black and that is not lots of
asteroid impacts on the moon turns out
that you can count a pretty simple
undergraduate project if you want you
can count large craters on the moon
divided by the age of the moon to
account for the fact that there was
something called the late bombardment
which was a busier time in the solar
system's history but you can basically
do this math and you can calculate by
earth you can essentially count the
number of asteroid impacts as a function
of asteroid size and scale it up for the
earth because the earth is larger and it
has a larger gravitational field but
fairly simple mathematics and you could
say how many asteroids on the largest
there are as a function of size not a
lot of doubt about that you can look it
because they're basically right next to
each other in the solar system you can
also look up in the sky and see shooting
stars there was a pretty good example of
this on February 15th a rock just about
the size of this room it was 18 meters
17 meters across exploded over
Chelyabinsk in Russia impact ii is about
500 mega or 500 kilotons excuse me so 20
to 30 times larger than the Hiroshima
bomb pretty good walk and it's the V
squared right it's uh M is big not that
big but V is big and V squared is really
big and that's where all the energy
comes from but it turns out that these
still open all the time to smaller
asteroids in fact there was one over New
York City
about a week ago probably about yay big
or so good rule of thumb if you want to
be smart at a at a party take the mass
of something reentering at a typical
speed that it hits the earth and the
energy release is about between 20 and
50 times its weight if it was TNT so for
instance a one-ton asteroid would have
an explosive energy of about 20 to 50
tons of TNT okay so some orders of
magnitude here 15 kilotons of TNT was
Hiroshima one Megaton is an
extraordinarily large nuclear weapon the
largest weapon ever tested it's 50
megatons so a and another good rule of
thumb one's cubic meter water weighs one
ton rocks about twice as dense so but
but it isn't you know necessarily cube
so a one meter diameter asteroid has
about 20 to 50 tons of TNT equivalent
which is a lot of energy that would take
out a you know a neighborhood for
instance I mean a good sized whole city
blocks
so it turns out that these things hit
the earth all the time the smaller the
asteroids are the more there are because
they're formed by a process in blue
that's where snap should break up in a
smaller piece so all we could actually
count these because they happen all the
time
and we monitor anybody have any idea why
we monitor for bright objects we have a
network of satellites looking down and
we haven't work all these without
sensors with sneakers a very loud sound
but you could actually hear that
explosion around the world but because
of that that data is the declassified
for the purposes of coming up there we
go
so the 40 years of data it happens
multiple times per year the smaller you
go down to the sort of you know this
size sorts of things you know you're
talking many many of those per year and
so we have very good statistics so you
can match that with the counting of
craters on the moon two independent ways
of calculating how many asteroids are on
you there's a third way we have
telescopes on the ground looking up for
asteroids now if an asteroid comes close
to the earth and it's it's then you can
pick it up at the ground-based telescope
and if it's on the dark side of the
earth not towards the Sun you can you
can see it and if the moon isn't full
and so on it's not a cloudy day you can
pick them up but we know what fraction
what volume of space we've covered that
way and you get 1/3 yet independent way
of counting the number of asteroids what
you get is this this is a power largest
reach and there is math in this this is
size of the asteroid versus the number
of asteroids the the blue dots are the
data a little bit of a strange tip here
I can talk about that but it's a
power-law distribution that means lots
of small ones not so many big ones and
you can change the the axes to be
instead of size because the speeds are
all roughly similar to impact energy and
megatons so you could label it that way
and you could take incentive number you
can write in how often they hit the
earth okay
fairly simple just axes rearranging
again this is the data this is Tunguska
this is 1908 June 30th there was an
explosion of about five megatons in
Siberia C&C had hit a lot this is the
one that knocked out the dinosaurs okay
so that's 10 to the 8th once every 10 to
the 8th once every hundred million years
or so and you know you can look at the
size here 10 to the 8th megatons okay
that's why it wiped out nearly
everything on earth okay basically
heated the entire Earth's atmosphere
around the planet to about 500 degrees
big giant flash fire most everything
died on that day okay so what are we
down here what are these sort of
interesting numbers here okay again the
interesting thing is you can see the
error bars are quite small so when
people talk about the discussions of
number of a story
they say well there's some disagreement
they're talking here 10% 20% okay so
it's it's not large and because of the
fact that it's three independent means
it's it's it's pretty not a lot of
modeling went on in there it's mostly
counting okay so let's put this thing
into perspective five Megaton impacts
that's a Tunguska 1908 was the last one
105 years ago it's about a forty
Christmas are actually a little under 45
meters to call it 40 meters the odds in
a hundred years it's about 30% okay
what's just consistent with the fact
that we saw one a hundred years ago so
there that the translating on the way
there's a 30% chance in this century
upcoming that there is a random five
Megaton explosion someplace it's kind of
interesting actually yeah just to put
that in terms of odds that people might
have a feel for that 23% is your odds of
dying cancer so that your lifetimes
about a hundred years so just for
comparison purposes so you understand
that day to day odds you know this is
you know your daily odds of dying of
cancer are roughly similar to the odds
of a five Megaton impact or her Korea on
the same day that that means true most
of the earth is unpopulated and if you
take a random spot on earth and put a
five medical tent explosion you may be
just fine maybe over New York City sure
would be a shame if the next one happens
over some place that's that we really
care about right so let's go a little
larger let's go to 140 meters like
something that would fit inside Stanford
Stadium pretty comfortably forty-five
meters is probably roughly this you know
half the size of this building or now
maybe roughly the size of this really
half the size of durán next door wonder
forty meters is would fit easily inside
Stanford Stadium that's an energy of
about 100 megatons for scale that's
about five times all the weapons used in
World War two including the atomic
weapons so that's a very big explosion
and in this century it's about 1% don't
worry soma again for scale your odds of
dying in a car accident according to the
National Safety Council is about 1% so
your odds of dying in a car accident
each and every single day is the odds
that on that same day will be a random
100-megaton explosion
three and so I always ask people hey you
were a seatbelt would you drive a car
without anti-lock brakes or airbags if
so why not
or why right generally people go all
that would be stupid not to dude you
know take common-sense precautions but
the question is what common sense
precautions are we taking with the earth
because even if this is not in a
populated area I posit that that would
be a bad day on earth at least you know
globally economically you know even if
it didn't kill 50 million people it
still wouldn't necessarily be good
yeah it's getting even larger let's talk
about ones that are one kilometer across
this is pretty big that's 40 Giga tons
the odds in 100 years are actually point
zero one percent not point zero zero one
percent or once every million years is
what that translates into but the NASA's
Spaceguard survey has found 90 percent
of those so in the next 100 years you
can drop that by a factor of 10 that's
why it is point zero zero one percent in
the next hundred years because we've
ruled out nine out of ten of them okay
that is almost exactly the same
according to the National Safety Council
of your odds of dying due to an
earthquake and we spend a lot of money
on earthquake safety up until a few
years ago it was a truism this is a
quote from my friend Dave Morrison over
at NASA Ames who said that the total
number of people working on asteroid
defense would be just about enough to
staff two shifts at a mcdonald's it's a
little more now it's probably about four
or five shifts so here's the interesting
part too
that's that surprises a lot of people
deflect the asteroids is actually the
easy part we know how to deflect
asteroids you sometimes read in the
newspapers about some crazy means of
deflecting asteroids some guy'll say
we're going to paint them or something
like that recognize that those are
mostly reporters trying to write some
kind of cool story okay
if like the answer is relatively simple
okay I'll explain to you why the
situation is this you know the earth is
on its orbit this let's call this the
orbit of the asteroid it remember
they're both just going around the Sun
inside an orbit which is stable okay so
it's just a repeating pattern over and
over and if these two trajectories cross
at a point at some point there's going
to be a collision if you ever remember
those old demolition derbies where you'd
have a bunch of junk cars driving around
to separate tracks and sometimes you
know as long as they get to the
intersection at different times it's
okay but eventually they run into each
other that's what this is the earth is
going around the Sun we know it's orbit
very very well let's say there's an
asteroid whose orbit crosses remember I
showed the orbits there's a million of
them out there that whose orbits larger
than the one that struck Tunguska the
sort of five Megaton case and this is
the situation and it's just a matter of
timing
if they show up there at the same time
there's an impact if they show up there
at different times all's well you got to
wait till the next orbit see what
happens right and that's why there's
about a million who crossed like this
okay across nearby and that's the
situation so how do you get it to get an
asteroid it missed the earth remember
it's all about timing the earth is
moving about sixty five thousand miles
an hour in its orbit around the Sun it's
about eight thousand miles across so
it's about one-eighth of an hour right
so it goes through the intersection in
about one eighth of an hour right
seven minutes right so even if you are a
dead dead square hitting it here if you
make the asteroid show up early by three
and a half minutes or late by three and
a half minutes no problem right so it's
just a matter of upsetting the time and
you're in the end you don't actually
have to change the trajectory very much
at all you need to change its timing
that's that's the proper way to think of
it so what you basically need to do is
make it be here when the earth is here
okay and to give you an idea of how much
that how much velocity and change that
is let me let me just move on here and
I'll show you how it's done but the
velocity change that you need in
general if you have decades of notice is
a fraction of a centimeter per second so
you know that's something like this okay
and remember that these things are
moving a typical op orbital speed around
the Sun similar to the earth sixty-five
thousand miles an hour if you make it
sixty five thousand miles an hour plus
or minus this when you get decades ahead
you'll find that it's it's a couple
minutes earlier a couple minutes late
and that's just because let's say I find
an asteroid 50 years before it's gonna
hit Earth that's its orbital period it's
close to one year because it's crossing
through Earth's orbit it's gonna go
around the Sun 50 times alright so in
other words if I make it each orbit last
longer by a few seconds and but it has
50 orbits you know it's cumulative right
so let's say it's a little bit slower or
a little bit faster by you know 10
seconds something like that 50 orbits
later there's 500 seconds all clear and
that's how you do it so the real
question is how do you make an asteroid
change its velocity by a fraction of a
centimeter per second and that doesn't
take much simple physics tells you you
simply just run into it it's called a
kinetic impactor which is a fancy
schmancy term for run into it with a
small spacecraft we've actually done
this with a comment it was a mission
called deep impact it wasn't for the
purposes of deflecting it but was but
it's the same same physics you just fly
and you just simply run into it it's a
you blow material off the surface that
tends to go backwards and and you impart
a slight change and if you look at the
amount of changing even and for most of
these sort of hundred meter cases 200
meter cases it's just fine if you need
to do it precisely you can do something
called a gravitational tractor you can
you can actually just hover nearby can't
your jets outwards so that the Jets
aren't pointed straight at it but
outwards hold position and this sort of
a fraction of a Newton of gravitational
force is enough to tow this so if you
need to do it a precise change this is
quite feasible and all current
technology okay
the hard part is you got to have lots of
warning right you can't be finding the
asteroid even as close as a decade in
your it's probably there's probably
nothing you can do if you're if you're
within a decade if you think about it
how do you even get a spacecraft there
right because it's going around the Sun
the earth going around the Sun it's got
to come close by the earth at a previous
point so that you have a launch
trajectory that actually gets there all
right so you know inside a five five to
ten years you may or may not even have a
launch opportunity all right let alone
how long it takes to build prepare it
and and test this thing so under a
decade this is extraordinarily hard not
to mention the fact that the amount of
velocity change is a hugely nonlinear
function often of time meaning lots of
velocity change needed in clothes and
foot and you can understand why that is
just sort of it just sort of makes sense
the closer something is to you the more
you know angular change you need to give
it or the more fractional change you
need to give it in timing wise to miss
the earth right farther out many orbits
ahead of time then you know a tiny
change in its speed adds up to a much
larger change you know many years out so
well you can actually use a new put that
but remember that in space you don't get
the same shock wave and so on and that
kind of nuclear explosion gives you a
fraction of a centimeter per second also
so you could you could also do it that
way but that's not going to disrupting
NASA so it's quite difficult as it turns
out and but even the nukes not going to
do any good if you can't even get to it
all right so the real key here is that
you got to get lots of warning and and
the beauty of it is that that's actually
possible okay we understand orbital
mechanics well enough that you can
measure orbits well enough that you can
get decades of notice so the key is
simply going out there and finding these
things and that allows you to know if
you if you need to do something right
I just thought this was a cool it's
actually on a t-shirt which a friend of
mine gave me so and here's somebody who
didn't take that for literally enough we
started a foundation called the b612
foundation about ten years ago myself a
couple other astronauts I got a name
rusty Schweickart who flew Apollo nine a
couple of planetary scientists and so on
and we were looking at the problem of
deflecting asteroids we're thinking of
it you know how do we go about
deflecting asteroids and us in a number
of other sciences over the decades so
realize hey this is really fundamentally
possible and that in fact it really the
most important thing was to find them
first because if you don't know where
something is there's my definition
nothing you can do about it right if you
don't know something's going to hit you
there's nothing you can do so about a
year and a half ago I was giving a talk
at Google and I mentioned this sort of
sad state of affairs that we knew how to
deflect asteroids yet we hadn't found
them you know again the numbers the
completion statistics which are on the
previous graph if you look carefully you
could see the red line below the other
one which it being a large scale meant
you have essentially found it very few
of them that we we don't know where more
than 99% of the threatening asteroids
are we've not tracked them yet we know
the total number but that doesn't help
you and yet we have the technology to
protect them to deflect them so we in
this situation where the next large one
to hit us would be one in which we
actually had the capability to do
something about it and I was remarked at
that's kind of silly you know we could
get wiped out you know those odds that I
showed you in that previous thing you
know 1% of 100-megaton impact in your
lifetime not that small we insure
against things a lot less likely than
that and this guy came up to me and he
goes huh how much would it cost to
actually find all those asteroids ago
well you know ground-based telescopes
don't do very well at this because
asteroids are dark they're almost
charcoal colored
they have typical albedo of a few
percent between sort of four and about
twelve percent 15 percent which means
that they're there they're hard to see
from the ground because they're all so
small right and again from the ground
you can only point your telescopes in
one way you need good weather and you
know wide field of view you're looking
for moving objects etc I said you'd need
to go to space you need to do this in
infrared because they're they're
brighter and infrared because they're
they're dark they get worn by the Sun
they have a typical temperature of 250
to 300 degrees Kelvin you'd need to put
this telescope not near the earth but
well inwards in the solar system so that
it can look outwards at the orbit of the
earth and I said it'd be a few hundred
million dollars that goes well so why do
you just go ahead and do it yeah typical
Google guy I used to work there so I I'm
familiar with the time so he he goes let
me explain I go I I'm like I don't see
how you could do that it goes whoa let
me explain he goes have you considered
the fact that you don't necessarily need
to do this as a government program he
goes well because could you put together
a team that could do this and how much
would it cost you a few hundred million
right here's well you know weird though
I just donated money to the San
Francisco Museum of Modern Art anyone
been to it it's right by Musco knee
center great place and they're building
a new wing on the museum and the new
wing at the time they were raising 400
million dollars for the new wing since
off the corner of the website right now
it's 550 million but that was this point
now he goes hey you know it's private
citizens and in San Francisco are gonna
raise the money to build the wing of an
art museum a wonderful thing and so if
we could build if we can raise a few
hundred million dollars to build the
wing of an art museum can you raise a
few hundred million dollars to save the
world and so that's when we decided that
that's what we were going to do name on
the side the asteroids that you're
deflecting
yes No
there we decided to go about this in
exactly the same way they raise money
for Museum of Performing Arts Center and
there's at any given time the United
States there are lots of projects like
of this size I mean on this campus there
are a number of buildings which have
been built by alumni that that are
pretty close in size to the project to
save the earth right a few hundred
million dollars there's been a couple in
the last few years actually in fact
Stanford's last fundraising campaign
raised six billion dollars right so
quite a lot more you know I so great for
Stanford I'm an alumnus so they asked me
for money but the point is that it
seemed doable
and so we announced last June that we
were going to in fact do this and we
decide to put together the team to do
this and it turned out to be kind of
interesting because there is a lot of
pent up frustration amongst us NASA
veterans in how things are run in the in
federal procurement how we go about you
know the there's a lot of rules that are
put on for very good reason for
preventing people steering contracts to
their friends and so on but those rules
also slow you down if you know the right
path okay
so I recruited Scott Hubbard who's over
next door many of you may know him he is
the he's the former Mars our former head
of NASA Ames one of the most experienced
spacecraft guys in the world I'm a guy
named Harold Reitsma who ran the science
mission he was a science mission
director at Ball Aerospace which has
built the Kepler space telescope the
Spitzer infrared telescope deep impact
for instance the instruments for Hubble
we recruited a guy named Tom Gavin who
was from the Jet Propulsion lab he was
head of mission assurance so he's making
sure all the missions work for all the
big missions for the last 30 years and
we essentially asked we asked you know I
asked each of them the same question if
you could do
a space project in a perfect world how
would you run it and they all said
exactly the same thing well you know we
go straight to the contractor that we
knew is the best one we would write it
as a you know if it was something where
we would not use technology that's so
far out there that the first thing you
have to do is develop all the technology
we would run it on a fixed cost basis
where the contractor has a recon track
this is Emma you know and then this is
the amount of money that we're gonna get
if we successfully complete this and
they thought that you could do this
mission for a few hundred million
dollars and then I said to all of them
well that's what we're doing you know do
you want to be part every basically
everyone on them said yes so we put
together what I think is the world's
finest spacecraft team and we started up
last year we signed a contract with Ball
Aerospace again they built the Kepler
space telescope which is finding
extrasolar planets and as well as the
Spitzer infrared space telescope and
we're building the following spacecraft
this is it called Sentinel launches in
July 20th 2018
this is about 25 feet high it is again
an infrared Space Telescope it has a
wavelength range of forward a little
over 10 microns and it is going to image
and look for these moving objects which
are the asteroids and what it is going
to do is scan the sky and then rescan
the sky and look for the objects that
are no longer in the same position and
we'll talk a little bit about that
because that's a very interesting
question how you know which object went
to where it's a very interesting
confrontation question but it will
discover roughly a million asteroids
over a six and a half year period
between 2018 and 2024 and it will be a
good way to think of it is that all the
other telescopes combined for the last
30 years have discovered about 10,000 of
these and will discover that about in
the first two weeks so it's just far
more effective just because of the
geometry where it's located not on the
earth but interior to the earth
and because it's infrared and so here's
where its orbits gonna be I'll show you
depict it it is going to there's its
orbit there's the earth it's actually
very similar orbit to Venus and this is
roughly what it can see as it scans
across the sky see you can find
asteroids that are in the it's basically
scanning Earth's orbit from this
interior orbit it goes around the Sun
about every eight months and so it will
over a period of years scan and pick
everything within its field of view it
picks up any contract we can piece
together the orbits and calculate if any
of them those orbits are intersecting
with the earth and if there's a danger
of an intersection and give ourselves
that warning so we're launching on a
falcon 9 rocket we're going to use a
gravity assist off of Venus to enter our
final solar orbit the telescope itself
is something that's interesting because
the the spacecraft this mission really
wasn't possible even I would say 15
years ago for a couple of reasons number
one infrared detectors were that science
has rapidly developed we did not have
detectors with low enough noise and low
noise is important because if you think
about what the detection of an asteroid
is it is a blip on the sky you know a
photon a bright spot on a pixel that is
not bright the next time right and it's
right somewhere else well that's
basically noise looks like moving
objects right so you need to get your
noise levels way down and that's
something that wasn't you know even in
this bit sensitivity in this bandwidth
low noise is not something that was that
was possible 15 years ago number there's
there's been huge advances in all areas
of semiconductors in the last 15 years
and it turns out there are other uses
for some infrared detectors you know
both military and civilian
you know night-vision goggles is an
example there's just huge advances there
have been missions flown that have
phoned cryogenic infrared detectors and
because of that you know they've pushed
it and each successive mission has
pushed the the technology along
the next thing is onboard processing we
are going to be if you think about it
between 30 million miles from the earth
and 170 million miles from Earth because
the earth is about 100 million miles
from the Sun and it's orbiting the Sun
at about 70 million miles so sometimes
it's on the other side of the Sun
sometimes it's on the same side of the
Sun and as all you all know from who or
anybody here who's an electrical
engineer knows about data rates the
further you are the smaller the signal
the lower the data rate you cannot send
that much data I mean it's a ridiculous
amount of data because what we are going
to do is scan the entire sky and scan it
again later that day and scan it again
you know a couple days later and if you
think about that enormous and you know
with a it's with these huge detectors
like there are detectors about that big
actually
you can't send that amount of data from
170 million miles away not without an
you know an antenna that's just
prohibitively large and using up all the
time at the Deep Space Network so the
key is to do onboard processing and this
is where the sort of computational
aspects of this become kind of
interesting I think elected to mention I
should have mentioned also that NASA is
now involved in our project what they
are doing is providing use of their
ground antenna system it's called the
Deep Space Network to transmit our data
so NASA does have an interest in finding
these these objects and our sort of pact
with the world is that as a non-profit
we're going to put all the data online
and NASA their role is to provide the
the antennas on the ground which they
already own and operate and we'll
receive a few hours a week of
communications time so what we do is we
store on board so what we do is we look
let me draw this little thing that this
is the the sort of field of view of our
our telescope so this is a picture of
the sky and this is what we're seeing at
any given time our detectors made up of
smaller detectors what you do is you
take an image of the sky then you take
another image and so on and
cover the sky then you come back an hour
later and you have to position this
thing exactly but that can be done using
guide stars and you take a picture the
same image right if the objects are
moving it's not in the same spot right
so you do that one hour later and you
get these points that are different okay
so if there was one asteroid in the
field of view it's an easy problem right
bright spot here bright spot here okay
what if there's two asteroids in the
field of view there's two bright spots
and now two other bright spots which one
goes to which right one of them is a
physical orbit meaning if that could be
an orbit around the Sun because it's
moving in a Keplerian orbit the other
ones likely to be non-physical meaning
if you look at the direction it was that
is not you cannot find any orbit around
the Sun that doesn't that it corresponds
to to those points right but what if you
go to three or four this is an N
combinatorial the difficult problem
right now considering that we're
tracking up to a million objects okay
this becomes an enormous problem so the
way we're going to do this is instead of
downlinking the entire picture mobile
majority of the pixels black all right
majority of the pixels of black what you
do is you you we cut out a region around
each object that is bright above a
threshold and we send just that area
down so that cuts down on the the
numbers of pixels that we send down
right there and then you just detect the
ones that you just send down the pair's
okay now which pair goes with which we
don't know yet so what we've done is
that you send down just the pair the
things that that you know move from here
to here the locations of the pair's but
I don't you know I send down pairs
essentially and on the ground there is a
routine which goes through and a big
multi processor routine which says okay
which ones of these are physical orbits
which ones can I even throw out if it's
gone too far
from here to here that's moving faster
than the speed of light you know so but
that depend on Allah distance from the
camera just yet so there
there's an algorithm that it does to try
and make it not end combinatorially
difficult and it's actually it's pretty
decent at doing this what we actually do
is we do this one hour apart and we do
it two days later and then do we do it
again 26 days later and that allows you
then to piece together these things
these things are called track 'let's
into Keplerian orbits so big processing
problem this is going to go on at the
Minor Planet Center it's it's located in
Cambridge and that's what they do for
the observations of asteroids currently
we're going to send them a flood of data
again our data rate is going to be
roughly a hundred times the current data
right from all other telescopes combined
so we are working with them to make sure
that they have their equipment and
facilities upgraded in time to handle
this but they're they're part of our
data processing team and we are will
then calculate it they will then
calculate the orbits this will all be
placed online and the raw date in fact
is going to be sent to other locations
too there is an independent group which
you do want to have that's located in
Italy does the same thing they have an
Italian version of the same program
written by different people because
again if you're talking about tracking
an asteroid they may hit the earth it's
good to have two totally independent
means of detecting it right and then
what you will do it for those that are
actually threatening is then because you
now know exactly where to point you can
point something like the Hubble at it or
one of these other telescopes at it
provided you know where it is you can't
do that until you make the discoveries
this is a survey instrument very broad
field of view Hubble is like looking
through a straw right so we got to help
we have to tell those telescopes were at
a point so that is the process again
it's gonna be very interesting times
starting 2018 and this in the end is is
what we're trying to do I you know we're
we're trying to protect this place and
it's kind of an interesting thing that
at some point our civilization has to
solve this problem right because you
know roughly every million years or so
there's something large enough to wipe
out humanity hits hits it's not enough
to cause a mass extinction but enough to
end human civilization that's about
every million years the reason we
believe that is that the one kilometer
asteroid if you look at how much dust
they throw up it in the atmosphere
pretty clearly would end growing seasons
both northern and southern hemisphere
for a few years and given that the
Earth's stockpile of food at any given
time is a few months that means you run
out of food long before you get any
growing seasons again and it's pretty
hard to imagine that that civilization
would look the same after something like
that it's about every million years that
happens and our feeling is that that
shouldn't happen and you know we're
working with the government we are
government a private public partnership
but we decided we didn't want to wait to
go through the you know the the budget
goings ons in Washington you know NASA
and the federal government have been
great partners thus far and you know
they're there they're very supportive of
what we're doing and we're gonna put
this data out there and they if we do
our job properly
you know this planet shouldn't be struck
by a large asteroid from this point
forward which is a sort of puts us in an
interesting time right I mean this could
not have happened a hundred years ago we
didn't have Rockets we didn't understand
orbital mechanics well enough we clearly
didn't have such telescopes but nowadays
we do and our feeling is that we should
deploy such a thing because we can and
because it would be kind of stupid for
us not to so that's what we're up to at
the b612 foundation if you want to find
out more
b612 foundation org is our website I
have
I'm testifying in front of Congress
again next week I testified in front of
the Senate a couple of weeks ago
discussing why it was in fact that we
didn't see the asteroid that struck
Chelyabinsk and the answer us because
we're not looking but you know it's a
sort of unsatisfactory answer that you
have to give but that's the case but you
know there's hope when we're operational
we will find we won't find all the
chalghi bins those who are fairly small
there are other ways to find those but
we'll find anything that could pitch
that would cause real damage we believe
and so it's it's going to be in exciting
few years how this goes to being built
right now so I'm happy to take any
question that you've got any comment
that you've got and you suggested you've
got feel free how long will it take the
satellite once it's there to see say 99%
six point five years the satellite will
likely last longer than that you can
continue the mission and what you get
then is the ability to find smaller and
smaller asteroids the longer because the
smaller asteroids need to come closer to
the telescope in order for you to spot
them so and it's a statistical thing
right because they're moving around you
just have to wait till it comes within
that distance of the the telescope the
interesting thing is that the map the
three-dimensional map of the solar
system that you create is good for
roughly a hundred years that's when the
orbits begin to drift due to non
gravitational effects and so that means
that you don't really need to redo this
survey for about another hundred years
so a beginning part of the 22nd century
is about the next time you'll need to
redo the survey in the back how much
data well I think it's
number of megapixels is in the range of
50 million but then you're taking an
image every 30 seconds so that adds up
excuse me 50 megapixels every 30 seconds
you know continuously yeah you get a lot
after at the end of not too long right
26 days come from that just happened to
be the tiling pattern that ends up and
by the way that that scan pattern that I
showed you in the revisit time they want
the hourly then the site two days later
and then the 26 days later is not set in
stone
one of the things that we've realized is
that you can optimize this because the
distribution of asteroids is not
isotropic it's centered around the plane
you can you can adjust both the cadence
of the observations as well as the scan
pattern to optimize some of these
numbers and they're doing that now over
the next year or so we'll have a much
better feeling how to optimize that so
you got a lot of variables you can play
with right do you want to do it so for
instance there's been discussion of
doing three observations in close
followed by instead of two days later
like to say something like six days
later with three observations in one day
you know is that better than two and two
it might be oh it's pretty big phase
space and what the way to solve the
problem is to build a giant mathematical
model that includes the expected
distribution own distribution of
asteroids in both in size and orbit your
orbital position your optical
performance the performance of the
detectors your your algorithms for
finding them and your data transmission
rates and then then vary them and run
turn the crank
all right and then you know vary your
parameters to see how things move you
know in terms of your overall detection
rate and we already know that what we've
done is not optimal but it works
but that's an ongoing research project
right now it's being done by a couple of
folks in Colorado right now there's a
number for it led by a couple folks in
Colorado kind of statistics do you think
you're gonna get what fraction is very
sighs no okay yeah will essentially be
astronomically complete down to the
hundred Megaton level 140 meter Astro so
that's astronomical complete is
considered around ninety percent and we
by the time you get down to the Tunguska
is at the end of six and a half years
you'll be about 50 percent complete
that's if you only go six and a half
years you know the the way most
spacecraft work is that they either die
early or they don't well beyond their
expected lifetime
we don't have consumables like a helium
Dewar we're actually cooled by a
mechanical chiller which is a mechanical
Stirling engine so we run at four
degrees Kelvin so we can run much longer
than six and a half years so my tongue I
believe you'll you'll mostly you'll be
in probably 80% range and I'm guessing
roughly again these numbers depend upon
how we end up choosing our our scan
pattern and our revisit pattern it can
be optimized more but probably get 80%
by ten years on the tunguska scale or
larger is a cryogenic cloud jet it's 40
degrees Kelvin but it is not using a
helium Dewar yeah yeah so thank you no
no crying no forty degrees Kelvin it is
using a mechanical cryocooler let's has
been used another other spacecraft
you're talking about a single large
telescope how did you say what the
diameter was the spacecraft itself is
about 25 feet high the optics it's a 50
centimeter IR if you send mirror is the
is the you know the main mirror size
there are a handful of earthbound
efforts the panned stars yes yes this is
one point
yes but none of those are an infrared
right and that's that that's part of it
which seems like a terrible oversight on
their part well no you can't do infrared
from the ground very well because of the
water vapor in the atmosphere and so the
we have two things going for us number
one is infrared and number two is the
vantage point that we've got geometry
adds awful lot to this it would seem
that this is a hugely partition Abul
problem and what lends big scope versus
ten somewhat less expensive scopes
versus no we looked at that it's not
really that partition of at all actually
because you bite off in a certain amount
of expense but simply by getting a
rocket and getting something out there
okay and so we did this sort of multi
dimensional optimization with size of
the optics observant you know the
observing wavelengths the operating
temperature of the focal plane you know
what whether we want to be 0.68 you or
0.8 0.7 or point nine one and in the end
you find out that you really quickly
converge upon a single telescope 50
centimeter optics four to ten micron and
it's a pretty solid solution and in fact
the National Academies did a study on
this independently and they came to the
same conclusion that was just published
about two-and-a-half years ago they
didn't independent study of this and we
based a lot of what we we're doing on
their findings so you do have an optimal
design but once you've done the design
work and engineering and prototyping and
testing and launched one what would be
the cost of watching the second for most
spacecraft if you buy a second one
you're in the sort of half or less of
the first one so we are looking at we
are raising 450 million dollars over 12
years and that pays for design test
fabrication launch rocket operations the
control center all people and margin so
that's typically when people call
spacecraft cost it caught they quote
just the spacecraft recording you know
total lifecycle cost so
I believe that if this mission was done
via federal procurement and not that
they couldn't do it they could
absolutely do it they'd probably double
maybe a little more and that was the
national Kennedy's estimate was a
billion dollars the interest or support
from any other government said Michael
Sam
nothing nothing definite there's some
discussions but nothing definite it's
one of those things where kind of
everybody's been looking to somebody
else to do it how much the flexion
mission costs to be really dependent
upon how big the asteroid is how many
years notice you have all sorts of
things like that
the a good way to think about it is that
the Deep Impact mission was probably
around five hundred million dollars so
puts it in the it's not you know maybe
one-fifth of a Mars Lander so it's
similar to the survey mission but yeah
so my feeling is that federal government
and the government's in general are very
very good at confronting a threat that's
definite you know once you find
something you will be able to say that
this asteroid will hit Earth on this
date at this time at this place in fact
the typical error ellipse for for these
things is about five kilometers so I
mean we'll be able tell within a five
kilometers or so where this thing's
going to hit okay five to ten kilometers
so if you issue a warning like that you
know this asteroid this size hits here
on this day my feeling is that that that
funding is an issue at that point what
long lead time planning can you do
before the warning I think it's prudent
to test a deflection mission on a
non-threatening ass principle right but
until you actually done it you know you
have
I think it's prudent and in fact there
is a discussion there is a European led
coalition that is doing a study on this
and there's a discussion that there
might be some European money to do such
a thing we'll see if that materializes I
think we'll provide them some incidents
we're gonna start finding so many of
these equipment it's gonna people are
gonna go WOW would be nice to actually
know that for sure that we can deflect
something back the only crossover or
communication with oh we know those guys
pretty well they aren't they are wholly
dependent upon us to be successful it
cannot find asteroids right okay so and
remember again an asteroid you don't
know where it is you cannot mine either
so there has been some statements that
that some of them are building
telescopes those are not survey
telescopes so they will not find
asteroids but if you tell it where to
point again you might be able to find
something perhaps if their objects are
big enough I don't know they're small
telescopes with you know sort of low
performance I don't know if that's even
possible or not I can tell you they will
not find asteroids though they're not
survey telescopes are they funny
providing you some of their funding
those guys know comets could hit the
earth but they are a good roughly 1%
number of comments versus large
asteroids and so we there's nothing we
can do about that that we know of right
now shouldn't stop us from solving the
99% problem I don't think but you
service you get billions of objects how
frequently do these millions of objects
interact with each other and not that
not that freaking so that that number
that I quoted that roughly a hundred
years is about when you begin to need to
redo this that's when they're these
little perturbations begin to add up
both gravitational perturbations as well
as non gravitational perturbations
things like off-gassing begin to have
enough
about a hundred year time scale so
that's they're pretty pretty much
Keplerian orbits to have very high
accuracy so what is the earliest impact
date that you think you could afford I
just again its its orbit dependent and
so on but we're launching in 2018 you
know if we found something right away
and it was within you know five ten
years you have a shot ten years you have
a pretty decent shot I think twenty
years you know the problem gets
radically easier the longer the the lead
time is so that's the danger you want
you know time's a-wasting right now
because again it would be kind of silly
for us to get wiped out for no
apparently good reason right because we
choose to not spend an amount of money
go into the lingam an art museum so
how's your fundraising going feeling
pretty good we only started real
fundraising last June June 28th actually
the day we started and we've raised
enough money to get through the first of
our eight major technical milestones
leading up to launch the eighth
milestone is launch the second major one
is coming up at the end of this year I
mean the teams ball in place the
facility the high bay where it's being
built has been opened we have started
building prototype detectors they've
been run down to 40 degrees Kelvin
they've been we are running additional
iterations detector work is a bit of a
black art we expected a number of
iterations and that's what we're doing
by the end of our next major review each
of the individual subsystems will be
will have its its requirements and
performance requirements specified and
how that all fits together with the each
with every other subsystem these things
called trade studies where you say hey I
want to make this thing a little bigger
or that thing a little smaller or
whatnot and how does it affect overall
system we've done as of about a month
ago we finished 75
those trade studies only expected about
another 50 more to go and we will have
preliminary data on some of our systems
by the end of the year so it's moving
pretty well so we funded all that thus
far yeah a few years ago there was a
talk of an asteroid that might have a
near a near miss in 20 or 30 years
Cameron Bure the name of it Apophis yes
Chris part of it but it was a it took
them quite a while to figure out
I saw projections going all kinds of
different directions
it took them quite a while to nail down
the orbital mechanics what
how are you avoiding that issue or what
issue did they have the issue is that
when you observe from the earth with
ground-based telescopes you can only see
it when it gets close to the earth right
now for asteroids whose orbits are very
similar to the earth let's say it's
orbit around the Sun is 1.1 years okay
that means it's near the earth one year
and it doesn't come back it's on for 10
years right it's on the other side of
the Sun you don't spot things very well
on the other side of the Sun and that
meant we went for long periods of time
with no data so you were just sitting
around going well you know and one more
years it comes back and we'll know then
right and that was what the cause of a
lot of that angst will prevent that both
because our ability to spot them is from
so much further away we won't have these
short periods of tracking where you only
see it for a couple of days and then you
don't see it for you know a year or a
couple of years we'll we'll track them
for months at a time so the error bars
will be much much smaller also you don't
lose the telescopes on the ground so now
you have two independent places where
you can spot for will at times be on the
other side of the Sun so if you combine
the the effect of both you actually
reduce that false-alarm effect by an
awful lot well I think it's because
unless it's in somebody's recent memory
they discounted that's just human nature
right
so until the events of February 15th
when that asteroid hit everybody was
going well yeah we know those odds but
ah right you know there there were a lot
of people in the city of New Orleans in
2002 said we should fix the levees and
we're gonna get hit by an hurricane but
the people in New Orleans chose to say I
don't even remember the last time a big
hurricane hit here
right look what happened in 2004 okay in
2005 they all said we better fix the
levees but nothing had changed
except it was in people's recent memory
and frankly people aren't necessarily
good at decision making we spend a lot
of money on a lot of things you know you
know there's value judgments in
everything right so I don't want to say
that you know one thing is better than
or another but in fact of the matter is
there isn't dispute about the odds and
if you think about it rationally these
are the odds that your root it's a giant
game of roulette with the earth right
each and every day we see if we win
right most days we win does that mean
but you can't keep winning forever when
you're playing the odds right
the way it is so we figured we just go
do something about it how much is it
gonna cost to move an asteroid that was
the question up here so my guess it
would be sort of a similar cost you know
few hundred million my guess but I mean
to do it in a controlled way that you
knew you know that you know again if
you're talking about something that
that's a clear public safety hazard
right you better make sure you do it
right so yeah here you said this data
would be public yes well it's about how
yeah we are gonna put it on the same way
every but all the current astronomers
put their observations online we're
gonna use the same system we don't want
to reinvent the wheel right now
everybody sends their observations
through to the Minor Planet Center it's
the clearinghouse and it's distributed
from there but we'll do and other
telescopes who want to do follow-up
observations can do that and they have a
warning system that if something is
close by the you know others can track
it if it's going out of the field of
and you know they system works pretty
well we want to work with the
astronomical community we're not trying
to hold tight to our data that's better
plan isn't there at least a small chance
that that will be misused to the
sensationalism like I suppose you know
yeah yeah yeah but I think in the end
you know I think openness is the right
solution I I really am against the idea
of hiding data from the public so I
don't I don't think we should get on
that road we're not gonna do that
how does one determine the size of a
distant object know its reflectivity yet
ah okay in optical you need to know the
reflectivity which is why optical
observations of asteroids have a very
large error bars because you remember
that I said the reflective is anywhere
between 4 percent 12 percent right so
you could be off by a factor of 2 or 3
in how you know how much so you know how
big that thing is surface area in
infrared remember you're looking at 1
minus that because it's the absorption
that you're looking at right because
it's rear ated so you're looking at 1
minus the point somewhere between 4% and
12% so in other words the amount
absorbed is somewheres between 96% and
80 something percent in other words it's
a pretty small error bar now and they
radiators back body and it's pretty
actually that's the other benefit are
going to infrared is it will have a good
handle on the size of them that you
don't currently get with optical once
you know the orbit then you know the
distance then you just calculate the
size from that how are you gonna deal
with the sequester I don't know how
we're gonna deal with that no but
remember we are a private organization
right so we are you know but god knows
what would happened if they shut that
tell their ground based you know
antennas down you know then we would
have to figure out a way to raise money
to do that ourselves and it's doable
right I mean these are that
you know people know how to build
antennas like I just don't want to
rebuild infrastructure that's already
there not a good use of our donors money
again if if you do want to find more I
b612 Foundation org if you think it's an
interesting thing if you want to get
involved sign up on the website
heck donate if you feel like it or tell
other people but to me I think this is
I'm hoping this is inspiring to kids and
to people that we can actually go out
and change the solar system in some way
to protect their own planet now that's a
fairly grand thing you know four and a
half billion years this particular
planet has been struck by asteroids and
it shaped the evolution of life on this
planet right there have been many mass
extinctions the the dinosaurs was one in
fact we're here as mammals because of
the extinction of dinosaurs but we can
actually we can actually stop that all
right we don't want to see our bones
like that that dinosaur and somebody at
some months future civilizations museum
and that to me is an inspiring thing you
know that I feel like this is a grand
project that's almost on the edge of
science fiction to consider of what
we're doing you know you're gonna modify
the solar system so that one of the
planets is no longer struck by asteroids
but it's doable you know and it's doable
using astronomy and detectors and
orbital mechanics and our and rocketry
and so on and I think that's wonderful
yeah we the the camera itself again at
the heart of it is a detector that's
about yay big it's mercury cadmium
telluride detector formed of 16 smaller
detectors that are butted up against
each other the the processing done right
on the backside
standard flight processing computers
they they have flown before I don't know
like the exact missions that they've
flown on before but we're trying not to
reinvent the wheel whenever possible
so the the telescope itself the baby the
baffling and so on and the structures
actually a reuse of the Kepler space
telescope bus because the the same team
built Kepler much of the optics is
derived from the Spitzer infrared
telescope so that allows us to do things
much more rapidly and cheaper because
there is a lot of a lot of design and
testing has already been done on that
that was a big part of why we were able
to bring this thing into our commercial
contract it is a standard that flight
computers are a little bit different
than you know computers here because
they you have to handle high radiation
environments and so there's a lot more
error correcting that goes on so it's
not really an Apple outs to apples
comparison you can't compare it to a you
know an Intel processor or something
like that in turn there there's a lot
more steps that go on there because we
are going to be fairly close to the Sun
there's a lot of radiation and you need
to be able to handle that kind of
raishin environment so maybe we can talk
afterwards but it's not us to throw a
number out there you'll be misled maybe
we'll make this last question so I would
guess the population you get a lot of
people who could care less mm-hmm you
get a few people who reba leave this is
important mhm
or I also suspect you might get a few
people who tell you you shouldn't be
doing this and that they're upset about
it have you had that I have not okay
I've heard mostly you know there's a lot
of people in the first category and
there are some people in the second
category and this is very similar to the
guys raising money to build a museum
right the majority people San Francisco
did not contribute to the museum but
there were some residents of San
Francisco felt it was important enough
that they have that new wing in the Art
Museum
that's what I'm wondering is what if he
can get some kind of feedback up like
you're playing God please don't do this
I have not said that no okay
and I suspect their tune may change if
it was actually headed towards them if
such a person existed and again I have
not heard that survey mission yeah we're
a little bit reserved removed from it
but anyhow well thanks for your time we
have done a lot of work and a lot of it
is online more that is going online
we're published started the first of our
peer-reviewed articles is and more
forthcoming and Senate yes our Congress
testimony actually you can throw fruit
at your screen if you see me on it thank
you